Hello World Suraj here.
Let's talk about five reasons to build decentralized apps.
He centralized apps or apps that are peer to peer,
no central server whatsoever.
They users connect to each other directly.
The first reason is that you would own your data.
The weapons become totally centralized.
That means a handful of apps on all of our data,
all of our texts and images and videos take whatsapp.
For example,
whatsapp was acquired by Facebook for $22 billion when it only had 35 engineers,
35 dudes on 500 million users.
Data.
Facebook didn't buy the 35 engineers.
They about the 500 new users data that they own and profited from profit that
those 500 million users should have gotten a little sheriff but didn't.
In a decentralized APP,
you would maintain ownership of your data.
People would pay each other for data instead of one group profiting off of all
of it.
Your data is your most valuable asset in a new data economy.
When robots begins to replace all Labor based jobs,
which are half of all current jobs.
The value that you provide to people that no robot can ever take from you is
your data.
Your five senses,
your unique perception of the world that you output with tweets and pictures and
videos,
you should be paid for it.
With decentralized apps,
you could be because you would own it.
We did use cryptocurrency to pay people for their data or piggy for hosting our
own dance.
It would create a new economy where everyone is earning money online,
everyone every day,
just by being on the Internet.
By participating,
you are contributing to the data economy.
The second reason is increased data reliability and a centralized APP.
All data historical on a central server.
If that central server gets shut down for any reason,
that data is lost forever.
So if you uploaded a really precious photo to Dropbox and Dropbox got hacked,
which has happened before,
that thought it was gone,
the link to it is broken forever.
It's just not sustainable in a decentralized absence,
there is no central point of failure.
You can choose to either Sawyer,
Dennis cheerlead yourself or have your data replicated across many different
clients.
It moves us towards a permanent web,
uh,
web where links never died.
Stupid for affords.
The third reason is faster data transfer.
We're moving into a new Europe data transfer soon.
We're going to be sending huge files across the way.
I'm talking petabytes.
Centralized absolutely allow you to retrieve data from one central server,
which can take forever to download restraint,
especially if it's across the world in a decentralized that if you want a little
website,
is that of your computer requesting it from a server across the world,
it'll find the nearest copy.
Maybe that random dude sitting next to you in chemistry has it on his laptop and
your computer would retrieve it from there directly and if multiple people have
copies of it,
your computer would request it from all of them at the same time.
The more peers,
the faster the download videos would load so much faster.
You could download games 10 times faster.
It's just better in every way.
The fourth reason is that it couldn't be shutdown.
Centralization means governments can block a website from reaching uterus in its
country.
For whatever reason,
the Chinese government has easily blocked Facebook from its citizens.
That's 20% of the global population,
and recently the Egyptian government is easily shut out the internet to stop
people from protesting.
Isn't that crazy?
And if the data center goes down or an ISP has an outage,
you're out of luck.
A decentralized APP could never be shut down by anyone.
Even if a government,
Chuck's down Internet access during protests,
people could still communicate with each other offline in their local area
networks by connecting to each other directly.
The fifth reason is it's the wild west of software.
We've barely begun to unlock the potential of decentralized technologies like
bitcoin and bitcoin.
The first people to make successful decentralized apps will be remembered for
many years and will provide a huge amount of value to the world.
If you'd like to learn more about decentralized apps,
check out the links in the description below,
and if you'd like to see more technology videos,
please subscribe.
I really appreciate it.
As always.
Thanks George.